plus humain les ardissons préférer la
plage
non j'ai dit ça
maintenant Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Stéphane
la semaine de ces jeunes
[Musique]
et voilà et voilà
les vacances c'est fini on était
meurtrier 29 polonais tués dans un
accident d'autocar 26 en juillet 3 en
août c'est moins bien une slovène
écrasée dans les Pyrénées l'ours France
car après cannelle exécuté en 2004 et
Laurence Boccolini a battu par TF1
temps couvert pour les plantesigrades
si dans de manège de canyoning et de
contrôle d'identité pour échapper à la
police
Ivan 12 ans rate un saut de l'ange du
quatrième étage être français ça se
mérite n'est-ce pas Jean-François sur ce
cliché notre ministre de l'Immigration
et Jean-Marie Bigard toute l'élégance du
bermuda
en revanche pas d'accident de barque
Sarkozy ne risque rien avec tous les
bourrelets qu'il a se gommer par Paris
Match il flotte
élégance toujours départ pour
Saint-Tropez Daddy inaugure la douche au
don Perignon 150000 euros le
rafraîchissement
les enfants du Darfour apprécieront
Paul-Loup Sulitzer a enfin trouvé une
femme qui l'aime pour son physique
Chirac en vacances se distrait avec deux
jeunes encore une ordonnance de viagra
mal à propos
d'humain les ardissons préférer la plage
non j'ai dit l'air d'ici envoyez-moi
envoyez les bonnes photos c'est la
rentrée quand même merde
mais tu es pourri
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
était pourri pas de canicule cette année
mais rassurez-vous nos vieux sont partis
quand même
merci à eux la chaleur s'était en Grèce
avec un an d'avance la flamme olympique
cabriait partout 50 personnes
carbonisées malheureusement ces deux
vacanciers s'en sortent
très hop François hotland change de
copine à quoi bon me direz-vous c'est
toujours lui qui fait les courses
pour oublier Chazal t'aurais-on pratique
la boxe thaï Sego il l'aurait bien
attrapé mes poussées incadies tout seul
c'est pas son truc un été au Pascal
Sevran fut malade aujourd'hui ça va
mieux il reprend ses activités s'il
pouvait tomber malade quand on est
rentré ce serait mieux
[Rires]
un été pitoyable pour nos sportifs aux
Championnats du monde d'athlétisme
rappelons tout de même qu'en juillet
c'est un Français qui réussit à stopper
un job en plein vol
[Musique]
gardons espoir nous serons champion du
monde de rugby la preuve voici un All
Black à l'entraînement et là attention
ouh là là un français
un été un peu fou même bouche a perdu
son cerveau ah bon il en avait un
était plus vieux mouvementé mais qui se
termine bien malgré une chute de jet ski
Vincent Lagaffe et toujours vivant ça ça
console de tout
d'autres n'ont pas eu cette chance
rappelons qu'il y a 10 ans tout juste
une Fiat Uno blanche disparaissait sous
le problème
hommage discrétion et un très bel
article signé PPDA sobrement intitulé la
Fiat Uno et moi avec à la clé un bouquin
en ces temps difficiles pour faire de la
thune n'ayons aucune pudeur à la semaine
prochaine merci et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu